We're in a grid world.
>> Okay.
>> And
you have to learn a reward function.
You have to learn what's good or
not good to do in this grid, and
you're going to get to
learn it by watching me.
So I'm going to control the agent.
The agent's name is Frank.
>> Okay.
>> So he's going to go like this [SOUND]
and then he stays there.
Okay?
>> Okay.
>> So
I claim that you can actually make some
very good educated guesses about how
rewards work in this environment, just
based on that one little demonstration.
>> I think that's probably true.
>> So is there anything that
the agent finds positively rewarding?
>> Green.
Yes, good.
Is there anything that
the agent finds aversive?
>> So, I could guess that blue is
aversive because you avoided the blue,
but that also happened to be one of
the shortest path to get to the green.
Yeah, that's true, that's true.
So it might have just been
a coincidence, but I think you have some
evidence that maybe blue was
something I was trying to avoid.
>> Right.
When I-
>> What about red?
>> So red is not something you're
trying to avoid because you
could have avoided it.
>> That's right.
>> I don't know about
orange because you couldn't
avoid orange to get the green.
>> Excellent, and that was
exactly the inferences that I was
hoping you could make.
So, again, you can learn a tremendous
amount about what's valuable and
what's not valuable by, not just the
path that was taken, but, in a sense,
by the paths that were not taken.
And what the other options are or
were and
what the other options weren't, right?
So you couldn't learn
anything about orange.
It could be that he hates orange,
not as much he likes green.
So Frank was willing to go through
orange and it didn't matter where.
But red, yeah, totally could've
gone around red and didn't bother.
Right?
So that you can avoid blue and
red just by going like that,
but he didn't do that, so
he probably is indifferent to red or
something.
So, yes, it's actually a really cool
idea and we can actually learn things
about what people want to do and
what they don't want to do.
How tolerant are they of like sudden
stops in a car or a bumpy road?
That sort of thing.
How do you trade that off against
how fast you're trying to
get to your destination?
It's hard to get people to
tell you numbers for that,
but it is actually not so
hard to have them demonstrate,
and then infer these kinds of
values from their behavior.
So, obviously, as we're sitting here,
we can't really get into
the details of the algorithm.
But just to give you a kind of
a hint of the form of this,
there's an algorithm
that I worked on called
Maximum Likelihood Inverse
Reinforcement Learning, but
there's a whole bunch of
different algorithms.
This one I happen to understand
the best because I helped make it up.
And the basic game is here,
guess a reward function.
In this case, we were guessing reward
functions that mapped colors to values.
We then compute an optimal policy
with that reward function in mind.
Measure the probability of the data of
the behavioral trajectories that we saw
given that policy and then compute
a gradient on how can the value of
the reward change in a way that
would make the data more likely?
And then we just go back and
do that again until we find
something that is a local maximum.
>> That makes sense,
how does it work in practice?
>> It seems to work pretty well.
It can be slow and
it can get stuck in local minima, but
we haven't really had
significant problems with that.
It actually pretty consistently comes
up with a reward function that's
pretty solid.
There's tricky things like
keeping in mind the fact that,
when I showed you the trajectory, I went
through green and then I stayed there.
So how do we represent that?
Is this an absorbing state?
And if so, do I just include
it once in my trajectory?
In which case, it just saw one little
green, in which case it's not so
excited about green.
Or is it really important and
it kind of sat there forever?
In which case it really didn't
see much of anything else.
So getting getting those terminal
states right can be a bit of a trick.
>> That makes sense, okay, I like that.